now last week mark 25 years since a gang
of racist thugs murdered Stephen
Lawrence Britain has come a long way
since with much of the traveling being
done by the police truth be told they
did have a lot of distance to make up
some not all practices and attitudes
seem to belong to the American deep
south rather than a nation supposedly
famed for its sense of tolerance but the
police have changed and that is why the
comments made by the usually learned
Archbishop of York
dr. Johnson Tom you are unhelpful and
deeply unfair
he said the report after Lawrence's
murder that said the police were
institutionally racist needed to be and
I quote revisited by every Police
Service so that they learned the lessons
that's insulting to everyone brave
enough to currently serve as a police
officer he's saying racism is normalized
and established in today's police yes
they have issues like other large
organizations but they have striven to
put right vile wrongs and the archbishop
is utterly misguided to reignite this
unholy Rao I totally see where you're
coming from to a point I do think things
have improved in the 25 years since the
McPherson report but I think if you ask
any particularly any man of color what
it feels like to be somebody that is
constantly stopped where the assumption
is that you are guilty and if you look
at the statistics black people or people
of color being me are eight times more
likely to be stopped than white people
and less likely to be carrying drugs
actually so I think I get where you're
coming from but in terms of the lived
experience of the people this affects I
would say the majority of them would
agree with the Archbishop of York Rick
because to be institutionally racist as
I'm sure you and it's really important
we do it is to say effectively but it is
absolutely normalized with the
institution and the blokes and women who
are getting up
got up this morning and will go and get
up tomorrow morning accept that racism
is in that is what it means is in the
fabric of their organization now have
they still got issues there are
practices that are the norm within that
institution that yield racist results
that's what it's saying so your
intention stop black people we mean
eight times more likely to be stopped
what is a racist result to black people
being a people of color being eight but
lastly before I throw it out if you talk
about a city like LA and they are less
likely to have drugs or firearms or
whatever it is well that's where I would
have to challenge it because if you look
at the possession of firearms and knives
drugs is an interesting one because
there is an enormous problem with white
males with drugs and and County lines
and white kids care but if you look at
possession of knives and guns that is a
problem
within the black community no I would
accept that that is a problem within a
specific group that are part of the
black community in London are those
tragic victims more than 80% of the
60-plus of Kidman killed in London are
non-whites I'm accepting okay okay
actually said if she's two type people
you end up disadvantaging them and and I
think the insidious thing about it is
that because people may be white you
assume they're guilty less and when they
are black is through they must be guilty
so how you get this out of an
organization requires clear vigilance
see what wouldn't you about matters I
don't think he did so that they were
institutionally vote he said I need to
be reviewed yes don't think he said that
their institution eros a my own
experience as I tend to giving you that
I think there's been a massive change
for sure I remember when I was at the
beach when I was running the BBC I went
to I was invited by John Stevens who was
then running the Met to go and talk he
died invited him to talk to our senior
management he invited me to go and talk
to this and what was interesting to me
was not what I was saying but it was
what he was saying he basically said so
that I won't put up with this talking
about race I won't put up with this and
I think there's been a massive change at
the top okay
whether that's changed
how much has changed down below I don't
know a lot of distance has been troubled
there are still issues I'm not
pretending they're not caramel ooh I
think Macpherson post produced a very
positive change and I think the question
we have to ask ourselves 20 years on is
25 years old so is would the police
today deal differently with the murder
of Stephen Lawrence and I think they
absolutely would do differently so so
massive massive changes has been made
what I think was was that every few
years some organization damage the
police again every every five ten years
the running me trusted to ten years ago
and the black Police Officers
Association did it recently too as well
as as well as the you know what you do
here is you it's a mass defamation of
every police force in this country and
it's demoralizing to all our policemen
who I think have changed hugely to have
to work under under this banner now of
being racist that you know I don't
believe they are racist you know many
people of many years ago when they when
they inquire what's happening didn't
believe the police were institutionally
raised the same there were voices at the
time that were saying the police went
institutionally racist but
institutionally incompetent in the way
they handled the Stephen Lawrence
enquiry and and the only conclusion they
could come to at the end of it you know
it was that because he was black it had
to be racist and that did defame every
police force in this country will bring
Michelle in in a second let's just here
you want to bring in coming after this
and a one of the relevant quotes from
the Association this is from Toller
Monroe president of the National Black
Feliz Association and Toller says I
think there has been some progress and
I'm grateful for the progress and the
increasing number of BMI officers but if
I was marking policing I would give us a
see at the moment we within the MVPA
would argue that we would consider at
least some forces are in Savannah can I
just come to the sentence because I want
to get Association its things because
there aren't the same equivalent
percentage numbers in the force
BMA is that on the population that means
it's racist but you know we've got we've
got to look at the fact that the only
reason black that's one of the things
they said but that but we've got except
that a lot of black people don't want to
join the police force
there's recruited drives in every police
force and
the numbers aren't there they don't want
time that's what we should be looking at
for sure all right I agree with Carol to
a degree in terms of I think it must be
quite demoralizing if you're just a good
person that join the police force
to do good to be told you know
institutional racism still exists in
what you're doing that must really
demoralize you and I don't actually
think that that's the case anyway and I
think that sometimes I wonder if we're
so afraid of being seen as institutional
racists when I think of like things like
Rochdale Telford and all the rest of it
I think wonder sometimes if we've gone
too far the opposite area child grooming
scandals just to remind the viewers what
we're talking about yeah so that makes
me wonder if we've gone too far the
opposite direction however I do have a
15 year old mixed-race godson and when I
talked to him he tells me that he does
still worry about things like stop and
search etc etcetera because of his skin
color so obviously things are not
perfect and there is still some white so
we don't get you made a really good
point there that he's saying that that
people are ethnic minorities were
treated with kids one of the accusations
after Macpherson was that police
officers on the ground was so paralyzed
by fear of going near ethnic minority
people that they they they turned a
blind eye to suggest that this was
watched to hell and rather let's move
away from policing to another address
briefly when you were running the BBC
you've got a lot of controversy because
you would determine to try and change
that how successful were you we made
some focus whether it's still there I
don't know even see this why was it we
want to know he made some why was it
important to do it because I think
institutions need to reflect the society
they're serving is the truth and if you
looked at the figures were actually much
worse than people understand because
most of the BBC centres are in big
cities where the it's you so you take
the national figures but they're not
relevant it's not even that it's the
relevant of the population in that city
so what he did in law I didn't I did a
lot but I basically set up a kangaroo
court I'll be honest it'll be just every
three months we would have every three
months we would have heads of
departments in so your figures aren't
changing why not and over time they
change how long were they given how long
was the department had given to put it
right
yeah I mean we were lucky though I mean
you remember this is a time of expansion
it's much harder when an organization is
cutting back do you think kids men and
women want to join the police I don't
think you can generalize like that I
think at the end of the day it's like
anything you've got to look at any
profession that has a low percentage of
whatever group and you've got to look at
how do you source talent from that
community what are you doing to reach
that community so I don't think it's a
there's an inspector of Wes York's
police caught Tania Wilkinson she said
that when she joined what she was going
to join her family begged her not to but
her community isolated her they called
her she was the black person joining the
force and so I I do not think that's
still right I think because the last but
one I took the passing out parade of MIT
police candidates at Hendon the last but
one on now Lord
Hogan House report said he's the
proceeding commissioner and he walked
down the ranks of you I didn't he might
have done it great no he's a tremendous
honor to do it it was to see London
there was every single color that it was
you they couldn't have worked harder at
non-white representation truly and can I
just add to that this isn't a problem in
America America has no problem
recruiting police officers from black
and ethnic communities so we just need
to look at what is it that they're doing
that works or maybe we're not doing here